what do the women that you've that
you've dated
say about like if we can if we find
these hundreds of women that richard
hart has
been with yeah even
even like the the good girls that you're
worth for a long time said eight years
what would they say about you now
i i think i'm the same guy i've always
been like just
fun you know
like
exciting i'd like to i'd twerk dance on
the pole we saw the ball picture baby
like i just
i am fun so i think that's what they
would say
i mean obviously the mind-blowing
orgasms may have left them
severe mental damage from never having
been able to get to that level again i
don't know like we feel like i
i'm good at stuff and that's another
thing i'm good at like mm-hmm i [ __ ]
like a demon bro yeah what's the skill
sport [ __ ] there's a lot of different
tricks like i could teach you something
you've got stamina you got skills blood
pressure man it's all about blood
pressure blood pressure yeah so like how
does your how does your body know the
difference between riding a motorcycle
and having sex timing right blood
pressure where's the blood why is it
there so like when you're making out
somebody you can pull your lips back
make them crunch their abs to get up to
you it's gonna force their blood
pressure up
um
choking spanking
smacking whatever like depends on what
the girl's into
this stuff all modifies like their their
mind space like so the girls are into it
are super into it so like there's this
if you really blueprint and figure out
what the person you're with really wants
what they really like and
everyone's totally different i mean i
hate getting spanked i hate getting
smacked i don't like none of that stuff
but some girls absolutely love it and
most people are afraid to try it out
with them and so they they very rarely
get to experience that and so you have
to if you want to make people happy you
have to learn what makes that person
happy by teasing and being playful and
you know just
you they're not going to straight tell
you like if you ask they're not going to
tell you hey what's that kink that you
know you don't tell no one about i don't
know
you'll never get it you want like i've
tried it's like you gotta you gotta go
through the work you know but if you
wanna put in the work ladies and
gentlemen if you wanna have great
experiences here i can see the comments
richard hart's a woman reader like yeah
dude but if your chick was with me she'd
beg me for it so this is the whole thing
rather than just the comments the whole
chat the um
all right so
in your future
lady
she better be into other women for sure
and she and you're going to get the kink
out of them yeah all right respect and
look if you're playing jane normalcheck
wants to do missionary sex solely for
the purpose of procreation i could
probably make that work a few times we
could try that
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]